if the house votes tonight for an early
general election my tenure as Speaker
and MP will end when this Parliament
ends and with that the longest-serving
and most important Speaker of the House
of Commons since the 1940s bowed out
from the stage he perhaps relished a
little too much look at the reaction
from the different sides of the house
this was a speaker who unusually divided
opinion but the opposition didn't hold
back in praise this Parliament is the
stronger for your being speaker our
democracy is that our democracy is the
stronger for your being the speaker you
will be described as one of the great
reforming speakers John Bercow was
elected Speaker in 2009 supported mostly
by Labour MPs rather than his own side
his relationship with his old
conservative colleagues was frayed then
and largely toxic now Prime Minister's
Questions the Prime Minister has
finished and he can take it from me that
he's finished he was also accused of
fostering a culture of bullying in the
House of Commons allegations he has
always denied but it was in his role in
a brexit process that he was at his most
controversial it's a someone who should
have been the umpire who always wanted
to be the opening batsman and the
opening bowler his sarcastic remarks to
colleagues were very cutting and he was
partisan berkos achievement was him
making the job less about ceremony and
instead instituting changes which made
ministers more accountable to Parliament
something for which many backbenchers
give him enormous credit this was
somebody who's prepared to assure that
we as backbenchers as parliamentarians
@lc and our view about how this house
was managed and he was absolutely right
to stand up for the rights of Parliament
and to challenge the executive when
necessary but in choosing to leave
office on brexit day Berko has even
departed the chair controversially with
all of the resignations Alex
from the Conservative Party the next
batch of conservative MPs and perhaps
the next government is going to be a lot
more Breck City than this one and so in
resigning now in allowing this comment
to choose his successor John Bercow is
binding and constraining the government
for the final time John Bercow was a
powerful speaker but that's only because
he served in an era of small and no
majorities if that changes so too will
the role of the speakership his
successors might be more forgettable a
fate unlikely for the man himself Lewis
could all Sky News Westminster